اعلنت هيئه الطيران الروسيه استئناف حركه
الملاحه في اربعه مطارات في العاصمه موسكو
بعد تقييدها فجر اليوم وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قالت انها احبطت هجوما بمسيره على
موسكو وقالت ان المسيره غيرت مسارها بعد
ان استهدفتها اسلحه الدفاع الجوي وسقطت
على مبنى غير سكني في منطقه
كراسنوبريسينز ايه ودون وقوع اي اصابات
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان
سفينتين حربيتين روسيتين احبطته هجوما
اوكرانيا
بقرب مسير قرب شبه جزيره القرم امس الخميس
وقال الجيش ان سفينتي الدوريه اطلقتا
النار على القارب ودمرته قبل وصوله الى
هدفه جنوب غرب ستيف ستوبل في البحر الاسود
معنا من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
امين ماذا في هجوم المسيرات هذا الذي
يتحدث عنه الجانب الروسي
وكان اخر هجوم تعرضت له موسكو بالمسيرات
قد حدث في الحادي عشر من اغسطس الجاري
هيئه الطيران الفيدراليه الروسيه اكدت على
ان حركه
الرحلات الجويه عادت في المطارات الروسيه
في العاصمه طبعا موسكو الاربع وهي ماشيه
هذه المطارات التي كانت قد فرضت قيود على
حركه الملاحه الجويه عليها عند فجر اليوم
اي بتزامن مع هذا الهجوم طبعا يبدو ان مثل
هذه الهجمات عثمان باتت استراتيجيه واضحه
تتم بشكل منتظم تحاول فيها اوكرانيا
استهداف العمق الروسي وتحديدا العاصمه
عندما نتحدث عن منطقه كراستحدث عن منطقه
غير بعيده عن مركز مدينه موسكو وعن مبنى
البيت الابيض وهو مبنى الحكومه الروسيه
ومقرها وهناك ايضا مقرات حكوميه
استراتيجيه عديده تقع غير بعيده عن تلك
المنطقه التي تقول الدفاع وايضا عمده
موسكو على ان هذا الهجوم تم احباطه ولم
يخلف اي خسائر ماديه او بشريه من موسكو
وامين درغامي شكرا جزيلا لكم